do you refer to yourself as an addict I
fully identify as an addict alcoholic
when I was 15 i guzzled vodka I almost
died from alcohol poisoning Wow I would
be drunk and be start like
hyperventilating and and freak out and I
made my friend called 9-1-1 once cries
to me and her daughter's didn't speak
for three years while she struggled with
dependency I remember having a lot of
frustration towards you in the times
like you called going away to treatment
camp you know like I had so much of this
undealt with anger another revelation
her marriage to Ashton Kutcher was just
as traumatic I ended up pregnant and
then I lost the baby
and almost six months so much of that
time especially was Ash and I was so
angry because I felt like something that
was mine had been taken away yeah it was
like oh we're not enough but then I
found these pictures and I was like oh
my god I saw how big her stomach was and
I was like oh my god like I was so
insensitive
the addiction in the codependency I
liked my addiction to Ashton and that
was probably almost more devastating
because it it took me seriously away
emotionally you know watching the
behavior with Ashton those years I felt
very forgotten and I felt like I develop
and I nurtured a narrative that she
didn't love me the ladies get candid
about their relationship and find
healing around the red table with Jada
and her family how are you guys doing
it's time to hold hands be such a
powerful powerful
[Music]